[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
isn't it
there's a serial killer
i want your perspective
first anniversary
what makes is think i'm so cheap
i thought you'd be curious
you think i cut off of this stuff
don't you
you're pictures
[Applause]
it's violence
it's broke
he likes little puzzles doesn't he
so ridiculous
thank you for planning this it's all
alive
[Music]
he's a nobody
wants to be somebody
that's the mayor
the commissioner
yeah
he's got ambition
this is very very personal
he feels these people have all wronged
him
probably goes way back
unhealthy
stormwatch money
why is he writing to me
maybe
he's a fan of yours
well maybe he's got a grudge against you
too
maybe you're the main cause
any theories
oh yeah really
you're normally so happy
but something is different
this time
this is very upsetting to you let's get
back to you why
you are so much more fun to talk about
me what are you here to talk about i
want to know how he thinks you know
exactly how he thinks have you read this
file
you two have so much in common
masked adventures
so he's even more righteous
are you afraid he makes you look soft
i'm wasting my time
i
think
you don't really care about his motives
whether he loves or hates you
i think somewhere deep down
you're just terrified
because you're not sure who you are huh
you think they deserved it
you think they deserved it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you